c'est une des villes du département où
la bataille s'annonce est rude
trois listes affronter celle de l'équipe
en place et c'est la candidate de gauche
marie fauves et qui a détrôné le maire
sortant henri bonnyaud un bouleversement
qui divise encore les clunysois je pense
que la liste qui était au pouvoir
pendant six ans n'a pas fait ce que
devrait faire pour une ville complot
niveau niveau tourisme et au niveau des
infrastructures dans la ville
malheureusement cette équipe qui est
arrivé l'économie ne savent pas ce que
c'est alors que ça va être la première
la première stratégie qu'il fallait
encore où j'ai pas entendu parler
d'économie la santé c'est pareil et
allégeant très bien dans cette liste et
ils seront apaiser les tensions
les discordes entre le maire de droite
et son prédécesseur de gauche actuel
président de la communauté de communes
ont mobilisé les électeurs
55 % d'entre eux se sont rendus aux
urnes
cette large victoire de la gauche
illustre le désaveu de l'édile déchu
c'est à lui de faire son analyse mais
effectivement je pense qu'il a il a
quand même
était pas forcément très très actif il a
réussi à se mettre à dos un certain
nombre de personnes importantes dans la
commune personnel municipal les
associations dont beaucoup de monde qui
était quand même en souffrance et en
attente de changement bon en plus je
pense qu'on peut on peut quand même
évolué pour que l'univers plus
d'écologie de solidarité de
bienveillance et on pourra faire que
mieux que ce qui s'est passé dans la
mandature précédente
cette nouvelle équipe municipale se fixe
déjà un objectif ambitieux obtenir le
classement de cluny au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco